>>> IN GEORGIA, REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP IS LEADING
HIS BID FOR RE-ELECTION AGAINST
DEMOCRAT STACEY ABRAMS.
KEMP FAMOUSLY DID NOT HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN HIS PRIMARY.
TRUMP PREDICTED HE WOULD GO DOWN
IN FLAMES AT THE BALLOT BOX AND
TODAY WILL CAMPAIGN WITH FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE,
HOWEVER.
I SAT DOWN WITH KEMP TO TALK
ABOUT THIS ALL-IMPORTANT MIDTERM
ELECTION, HOW HE SEES TRUMP'S
ROLE IN ALL OF THIS, AND THE
IMPACT OF THE OTHER REPUBLICAN
IN HIS STATE HERSCHEL WALKER ON
THE TICKET.
>> Reporter: WITH ONE WEEK TO GO
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
MORE THAN 1.6 MILLION VOTERS IN
GEORGIA HAVE ALREADY CAST THEIR
BALLOTS.
>> IT'S SURPASSED LEVEL OF 2018.
ALMOST PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
LEVEL.
>> INCREDIBLE.
>> Reporter: GEORGIA RESIDENTS
TURNING OUT IN DROVESING IN THE
FIRST ELECTION SINCE PRIOR
GOVERNOR KEMP ADDED RESTRICTIONS
TO ABSENTEE VOTING EXPANDING IN
OTHER COUNTIES.
>> IMPRESSIVE, NUMBERS DON'T
PLAY THAT FACT OUT.
>> WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY --
>> Reporter: THE BILL EARNED HIM
FIERCE CRITICISM FROM DEMOCRATS
IN GEORGIA.
>> VOTER SUPPRESSION IS ALIVE
AND WELL IN GEORGIA.
>> Reporter: AND INSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> THIS MAKES JIM CROW LOOKS
LIKE JIM EAGLE.
>> HAD A RECORD VOTE IN PRIMARY
AND SEEING IT NOW IN THE GENERAL
ELECTION.
>> Reporter: BUT AS KEMP MAKES
HIS FINAL CAMPAIGN STOPS THE
ELECTION DRAMA IN HIS STATE IS
CENTERED AROUND THE OTHER
REPUBLICAN ON THE TICKET.
KEMP IS VOTING FOR HERSCHEL
WALKER BUT SAID LITTLE ELSE
ABOUT THE ALLEGATIONS THAT THE
GOP SENATE CANDIDATE PAID FOR
ABORTIONS DESPITE PUBLICLY
OPPOSING THE PROCEDURE
ALLEGATIONS THAT WALKER HAS
DENIED.
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
MAKE THAT CLEAR CHOICE AS WHO
THEY'RE GOING TO VOTE FOR NOT
JUST IN THE U.S. SENATE RACE UP
AND DOWN THE BALLOT.
>> Reporter: PRESSED WHETHER HE
VIEWS WALKER'S STANCE AS
HYPOCRIICAL KEMP SIDESTEPPED
THE MATTER.
>> SAY TO HER VOL WALKER
POLICIES ON ABORTION, I'M
FOCUSED ON MY RACE WHAT I CAN
CONTROL AND TRYING TO HELP THEM
FIGHT THROUGH JOE BIDEN'S
INFLATION.
>> Reporter: THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR INSTEAD CENTERED HIS
RACE ON THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE HE
HEARS FROM VOTERS.
INFLATION.
>> EGGS UP 30%, MILK, CHICKEN UP
15%, 17%.
GAS PRICES, BAD DOMESTIC ENERGY
POLICY.
NUMBER ONE ISSUE.
60% OF AMERICANS LIVING PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK.
>> Reporter: A NOTICEABLE
ABSENCE ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT NOT IN
GEORGIA THE PAST FEW MONTHS.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
ASK HIM THAT QUESTION.
LOOK, I'M FOCUSED ON GETTING OUR
VOTE OUT.
>> Reporter: DESPITE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BEST EFFORTS
KEMP PREVAILED EARLIER AND
EASILY DEFEATED HIS TRUMP-BACKED
OPPONENT THT I'M NOT CAMPAIGNING
ON WHAT HIS RECORD WAS.
I'M CAMPAIGNING ON WHAT I'VE
DONE IN THIS STATE.
>> Reporter: KEMP'S VICTORY
REVEALING LIMITS OF TRUMP'S GRIP
ON THE PARTY AND HIS EFFORTS TO
UNSEATED THOSE WHO REFUSE TO
JOIN HIS FIGHT TO OVERTURN THE
2020 ELECTION.
>> I DON'T THINK IN 2020 WE DID
A GOOD JOB IN SOME OF OUR RACES
OF LETTING PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
WE'RE FOR.
WHAT OUR RECORD IS.
EVEN WHEN YOU DISAGREE WITH
PEOPLE, IF YOU STAND FOR
SOMETHING, THEY HAVE GREAT
APPRECIATION FOR THAT.
>> Reporter: KEMP UNSUCCESSFULLY
FOUGHT A SUBPOENA TO APPEAR
BEFORE A SPECIAL GRAND JURY IN
ATLANTA MR. TRUMP'S ATTEMPTS TO
UNDERMINE THE ELECTION AND MUST
TESTIFY ONCE HIS ELECTION IS
OVER.
>> TELL THEM THE TRUTH AND THAT
I FOLLOWED THE LAWS AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THIS STATE.
>> OF COURSE, HE AND ABRAMS MET
AGAIN SUNDAY NIGHT IN A DEBATE
TALKING ABOUT THESE EARLY RECORD
TURNOUT NUMBERS SEEING IN
GEORGIA.
SHE BELIEVES PEOPLE ARE VOTING
IN SPITE OF THAT ELECTION BILL
HE SIGNED INTO LAW.
NOT BECAUSE OF IT.
I THINK ONE PART NOTABLE,
GABRIEL STERLING, TOP OFFICIAL
IN THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE BECAME NOTABLE DURING
TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO UNDERMYRON
THE RESULTS, SAYING VOTER
REPRESSION A MUCH AS -- WE'RE
SEEING A SPLIT.
>> AND CAME OUT WARNED AGAINST
WHAT ALL OF THIS VIOLENT
RHETORIC AND ELECTION DENIAL
WOULD DO.
MEANING PEOPLE WOULD DIE.
HE SAID THIS YEARS AGO.
THE QUESTION NOW LOOK AT ALL THE
HEAT KEMP ARPD THE REST TOOK
FROM SB-202, THAT BILL, WHAT'S
MISSED IN THE CONVERSATION THERE
ARE RESTRICTIONS BUT IT DOES
EXTEND EARLY VOTING BY WEEKS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING PLAY
OUT RIGHT NOW.
ISN'T IT?
>> I THINK IT'S HARD TO SAY THAT
THERE IS AN EFFORT FOR VOTER
SUPPRESSION WHEN YOU LOOK AT
PEOPLE PUSHED OUT OF THE --
>> BUT WHO IS VOTING?
>> AND THE ACCESS THAT THEY HAVE
AND PEOPLE TRYING TO CUT OUT ON
YOU KNOW, GETTING TO POLLS ALL
THAT STUFF.
DEPENDS WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT,
WHAT DATA YOU'RE LOOKING AT,
AND, LOOK, I THINK RATHER THAN
TRYING TO RESTRICT PEOPLE HERE
AND THERE WE SHOULD BE OPENING
UP THE VOTING PROCESS.
IT SHOULD BE AS EASY TO VOTE AS
POSSIBLE.
AS IT IS TO GET A CUP OF COFFEE,
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
VOTE.
>> TO DON'S POINT.
ISN'T THIS WHAT STACEY ABRAMS IS
SAYING?
YOU DON'T KNOW WHO IS GETTING
ACCESS, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S BEEN HER ARGUMENT
SHE'S MAKING AND A POINT OF
CONTENTION BETWEEN OF TWO OF
THEM.
I'LL SAY ONE THING.
SAD IT STANDS OUT BUT IT DID IN
THE DEBATE AS I WATCHED SUNDAY.
BOTH CANDIDATES ASKED IF THEY
WOULD ACCEPT RESULTS OF THE
ELECTION NO MATTER WHAT THEY ARE
THEY BOTH SAID THEY WOULD, YES.
>> AMEN.
CAN'T BELIEVE WE HAVE TO
CELEBRATE THAT, BUT AMEN.
>> YOU HAVE TO ASK THE OTHER
GUY.
HE ASK ON THAT.
>> YEAH.
>> OBVIOUSLY DON'T FORGET.
ONE WEEK FROM TONIGHT CNN'S
SPECIAL COVERAGE OF THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS UNDER WAY.
WE BEGIN AT 4:00 P.M. IN THE